perhaps daunted by gutfeld superior
ratings i hate to say this but he's got
them liberal late night hosts putting
aside attempts at being funny last night
teaming up to demand action on climate
change
eight late shows including this one are
doing climate climate-themed nights okay
crisis solved
you're welcome
this is how bad climate change is
getting wildfires in the west floods in
the east freezing cold in texas billy
joel is going to have to write an update
for 2021 and call it actually we did
start the fire the pandemic uh systemic
racism income inequality immigration gun
violence but here's the thing if we
don't address climate change none of
those issues will matter at all thanks
to climate change we're looking at a
future of no sex and tons of violence
i i didn't get that one at all who do
you think they're trying to convince
uh i think that they're trying to
convince their their uh i guess
hollywood yeah advertising they're yeah
they're advertisers so they don't lose
their jobs when you look at that picture
of them all together
if you show that can you show that it
looks they look like a class of
disneyland live performers about to do a
live play on planet earth right they're
like it's like a child's tv show that
that is like
insanely nauseating they've replaced
comedy with tragedy i mean kimmel
talking about who wants to go who wants
right before they're going to bed listen
to listen to people lecturing and
hectoring them about how the world's
going to end this is really like a cult
they've replaced george carlin with
george soros
but put that picture back i want are you
jealous that you're not in that picture
i am so
you can't deny that the world is hotter
and drier than it has been the people
are hotter okay the world has also been
hotter and drier before human beings
existed on the planet we've had very hot
parts of the earth we've had oceans over
places like arizona where i'm from where
you can find seashell fossils at the top
of the grand canyon so yes the climate
does change whether you can take
billions of dollars and throw it into
some climate paris accord and change
the temperature of the earth is i think
a very arrogant proposition
but you know greg i just love to be
terrified about how i'm going to die
right before i go to bed because
nightmares are drowning or everything
but maybe they should do something that
actually matters like i don't know walk
around new york city and pick up masks
that people have thrown away you know i
saw that video from the grand teton
national park and there's a grizzly bear
walking around with a mask in his mouth
so you know what baby that was a pig
that was a big bear he was a fake bear
the hiker was inside
but isn't it
we have seen
climate change go from speculation dana
to uh absolute fact in the minds of
people based on their politics rather
than their science i find that alarming
well i i do think that in some ways
they're preaching to people who already
believe and what they believe but i
think one of the frustrating things is
that you actually don't talk about real
solutions and one of those things would
be like you know if
it takes
the carbon footprint of one hour of
television is more than two residential
families right so there's these
trade-offs and backs and forth and there
are great innovations that are happening
right now great stuff on battery
technology really good stuff on carbon
capture things like that that kind of
innovation is what's going to help solve
this problem not telling people
basically to not do anything and then
these oh nuclear and geo uh what's that
other one
thermal no
fusion fusion
gps but there's a lot of innovation and
that's what will actually help solve it
and
when you see comedians do you think that
what do you think performance do you
think show business personalities can
they move the needle well they used to
carson used to get nine million a night
leno went to six i said that's not the
needle i meant colbert was only getting
what two million a night now so they're
not influential also they watch it
they're too partisan those old guys they
weren't that partisan and people were
influenced by the remember they used to
have the telephone seraldo yeah and they
used to race i was on tons of of course
you were all of course they were
probably you're one more gary lewis
but they used to actually put pictures
up of i don't want to scale it
distributed
starvation earthquakes and it used to
bring tears to people's eyes they pick
up the phone and donate
is climate change that type of immediate
threat what's a wave gonna go over the
dune in nantucket and get theresa hines
carry estate a little damp come on
there's real stuff like fentanyl and i
don't know pandemics china china that we
just talked about in the last segment
they'd be better served doing something
about that how can you talk climate
change in china excuse me i just think
it's just a lot of virtue signaling from
people who don't live the way that they
preach hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else